Hey everybody, this is Brent Dixon. I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 192 in St Cloud, Florida.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is very happily sponsored by backers like me. Thanks, Clark.
And now it's the old scout master.
Have you heard about the scout who was so interested in knots he would only eat Thai food?
Oh, you haven't heard about that yet,
Oh dear. Well, this is podcast number 216..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Mike Beck wrote in about our post of a week or so ago about scouting as craftsmanship
And he said: it's true, we should think of scouting as craftsmanship rather than as a form of institutional or mass production education.
We often see instruction as holding a class, but that is not scouting.
Your podcast on Introduction to Leadership Skills for Troops was timely for us.
We're revamping the way that we present it as to make it more of a bite-sized and immediately practicable kind of thing.
Our aim is that we won't just present one long training session,
but we'll have a shorter initial event that will facilitate more active mentoring with the adults and the patrol leaders council.
Thanks for getting in touch, Mike. You know I found something that Biden Powell said after the podcast where we were talking about training youth leaders,
He said this: the method is to lead the boy to tackle the objective of his training and not to bore him with the preliminary steps at the outset,
which I think addresses the subject very well, don't you?
I also heard from Rob Knapp, who is with Scout Troop 348 in Reiner, Virginia.
He says: I've been a scout master for a little over three years now.
Three years ago we thought that a scout run troop meant giving scouts a meeting outline, but it really wasn't their troop,
They were just following an adult plan.
I found your blog about seven months ago and after listening to the podcast for a month, you gave me the courage to work towards becoming a truly scout run troop.
I'm happy to report that the patrols are functioning well. Our senior patrol leader is following up with his patrol leaders.
In our meeting room we have a whiteboard that has upcoming activities listed on it.
At tonight's meeting one of the parents pointed out a mistake in the schedule
and I told the parent. I thought this mistake was a great opportunity and he kind of looked at me strangely.
I asked the senior patrol leader if he had looked at the whiteboard and he said he hadn't.
But just by bringing that to his attention. by the end of the meeting the scribe had corrected the mistake, with no further adult involvement.
You know this stuff really works. Thanks again for all of your help.
Thank you, Rob, for getting in touch, and Rob had an email question that you're going to hear a little later on too.
Before we go any further, if you found the blog and the podcast and the other resources that we offer to be useful,
you can return the favor by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
Funds that we receive from backers go to help with the expenses involved in producing these resources
and making them freely available to scouts all over the world.
I want to thank Brent Dixon, who you heard earlier in the podcast, who signed up as a backer this past week.
Thank you so much, Brent.
I also wanted to remind you you can join 1,900 other scouters who have the Scoutmaster CG app installed on their mobile device.
The app will give you access to the podcast and the podcast archive and the blog and other resources that we've created,
and you can get the app on Google Play and at iTunes.
Well, in this edition of the podcast, we're going to talk a little bit about positive peer pressure in Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less,
and it's really under seven minutes this week. so I'm reminded of the saying that even a blind pig roots up a truffle every once in a while.
And then we've got some email questions to answer and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast. so let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less?
During a visit from a Weebelos den at one of our troop meetings, a scout was available to speak with the parents of the visiting Weebelos,
and that week the older scouts had been leading a discussion with our younger scouts about disabilities awareness merit badge.
One of the parents was impressed that the older boys were leading discussions on the subject and asked this older scout:
how do you get the older scouts to do this, How do you get them to lead a discussion with the younger ones on such an important subject?
And the scout answered that he had watched the older scouts when he was younger and learned how to do things like lead discussions.
It all seemed, you know, pretty natural and unremarkable to him,
And I think that this is representative of what I like to call positive peer pressure.
It's something that takes a little time to develop if it isn't already present in a troop.
Perhaps the most important influence on building this kind of positive peer pressure is the way that the scout master and the other
scouts model the acceptance of and respect of new scouts. when they arrive,
New scouts don't have anything to prove to us, They don't have any tests to pass.
They become full members of the troop as soon as they walk through the door.
So if we are respectful of each other and we also delegate actual responsibility to our youth leadership
and we praise their accomplishments and we accept their failures with grace and equanimity,
we start sending a message about how people are treated in scouting.
Everyone rises or falls to positive or negative expectations of their leaders and their peers.
Some of our scouts will be at an age where they don't put a whole lot of importance on the opinion that adults have of them.
They're in the throes of developing their own personality, going through adolescence,
and you know what I'm talking about.
If you've ever lived in the same house with a 13,, 14-year-old scout, you know exactly what I'm talking about.
But when they are in an atmosphere of acceptance and where adults treat them with some respect
and adults give them responsibility, they're likely to spend a shorter amount of time
in that kind of difficult period that all of us go through,
If we maintain really positive, high expectations of behavior and performance and spirit,
that's what we're going to see.
If we reinforce those expectations with minimal and tempered and positive, constructive discipline,
younger scouts internalize those signals and they see the way older scouts act
and this kind of positive peer pressure is fostered
and pretty soon the younger scouts grow older to perpetuate the cycle.
This works both in positive and negative ways.
in the same way that, unfortunately, negative or difficult behavior can spread through a group,
Positive and constructive behavior can spread exactly the same way.
I encourage you to think in terms of positive peer pressure
and talk to your scouts about it and start building that into the culture of your troop
E-mail. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your e-mails.
I got this e-mail question recently and we're going to just keep it anonymous because of the subject matter.
If a local business wants to donate money to a local scout troop,
what BSA guidelines need to be followed?
We would not be a project or event for or at the business,
just a simple donation with no strings attached.
The troop could spend the money as we see fit: on camping equipment
or for paying for camping trips for scouts that need it.
We would not promote the business in any way.
maybe put a thank you on our website or something like that.
The answer to that question is a qualified yes.
A while back, I had in a blog post a document from the BSA
called Fiscal Policies and Procedures for BSA Units.
I will link to it in the post that contains this podcast,
but it's one document that every volunteer ought to read at least once
and then keep in their resource file so that when questions like this come up,
you'll be able to turn right to it and get your answers.
Here's the part of the document that addresses this question specifically.
Simply put, units are not permitted to solicit any gifts.
Both the charter and bylaws and the rules and regulations of the BSA make this very clear.
Only local councils may solicit individuals, corporations,
United Ways or foundations for gifts in support of scouting
Units, and unit leaders and youth members
may not solicit gifts in the name of scouting
or in support of unit needs and activities,
except in unusual circumstances where the unit has received permission
to do so from the local council.
Units are also prohibited from soliciting gifts on their websites.
Now, does that mean that people can't make gifts to your troop.
I'm still quoting the document here.
Units are not supposed to solicit gifts, but they can receive gifts.
Anyone can contribute to a scout pack, troop or unit
and many donors don't need or care about charitable deductions.
Obviously, defining a solicited gift is not always easy,
but we rely on our unit leaders to set good examples
and honor the intent and spirit of these important guidelines.
We know it's hard to stop people from being generous, especially towards scouting.
So the qualification in the yes that yes, you can accept a donation to your troop-
is if someone came to you of their own volition and offered a donation,
you can accept it.
If they want a tax letter, the letter comes from your chartering organization.
If someone in the unit or the chartering organization went out
and solicited this donation, well then you've crossed the line.
As I just read, only local councils can solicit donations
And the idea here, as you can imagine, is if units were permitted
to individually go out and solicit and accept donations,
you'd end up with some very well-funded units and underfunded councils.
So the idea is we want to not water one specific leaf,
That's the scout troop or the cub pack or the venture crew.
We don't want to just benefit them alone.
We want the whole tree- and that would be the council- to benefit,
And then everybody gets the benefit of those donations rather than just one unit.
If your unit was approached with the offer of a donation,
I would advise you to keep all of it as transparent as possible.
Get in touch with your local council and explain exactly what's going on
so there'll be no misunderstandings.
Then be sure that everybody involved with the unit understands
the rules about soliciting any additional donations,
because you know people are going to see this donation, come through
and think it would be a really great idea to go out and solicit others,
And you have to explain very carefully and definitively that that is simply not allowed.
In my personal opinion, I think a thank you letter to the donor,
hand-delivered by a deputation of uniformed scouts,
would be a nice gesture in recognizing the donation.
I would advise against mentioning it on a website
or in a newsletter or anything that could be misconstrued
as the BSA endorsing a business in any way,
As in anything that you hear on the podcast or read on the blog.
this is my advice, based on reading the policy statements that I can find
and my own experience.
I strongly urge you to contact your local council
and explain what's happening, to be doubly sure that nothing is misunderstood,
and to study the policy documents that I'm referring you to
and make sure that I've got this right.
I've been involved with council level fundraising issues
and I've learned that these policies are there for very good reasons.
What some misguided volunteers and units do to lavishly fund their leaf,
their unit, their small part of the council-
and I'm talking tens of thousands of dollars-
is pretty stunning.
It's not that councils are greedy,
it's just that when money goes to the council, everyone benefits,
All the units benefit,
And so the rules and policies are there for very good reasons
And naturally I recommend that you understand them and follow them.
Rob Knapp writes in to ask:
we'll be having elections for senior patrol leader soon.
The scouts will be electing the new senior patrol leader
and, as you suggest, that scout will appoint his quartermaster,
scribe chaplain's aides, et cetera.
Do you suggest that the scouts elect the assistant senior patrol leader,
or should the senior patrol leader appoint him as well?
Also, should the assistant senior patrol leader be present
when the scout master and senior patrol leader are meeting together
or just act as a fill in when the senior patrol leader isn't around.
Well, your question about how the positions of responsibility are filled
aren't a matter of opinion or choice.
It's really spelled out very specifically in the scout master's handbook
And quoting from that. the youth leader with the most responsibility
in a troop is the senior patrol leader.
He is elected by all members of the troop.
So we understand: senior patrol leader gets elected by the other scouts.
And then the scout master's handbook goes on to say- quote
with the approval of the scout master, the assistant senior patrol leader
is appointed by the senior patrol leader.
Okay, so we've got that piece.
And then in the scout master's handbook it talks about other troop positions
And it says this quote: depending on the size and needs of the troop,
any or all of the following positions may be filled.
This is at the head of a listing of descriptions
of these different positions of responsibility.
Unless otherwise indicated, the senior patrol leader selects the scout
who will hold each position.
The scout master can help the senior patrol leader
make these decisions on the basis of the candidate's overall qualifications
rather than merely on popularity or friendships.
Scouts serving in any of the following troop positions
will also continue to be active members of their patrols.
So the handbook then goes on to list the positions
of quarter master, scribe, OA representative, historian, librarian, instructor,
chaplain, aide, den chief, junior assistant, scout, master, et cetera.
And while they use the phrase unless otherwise indicated
to modify the idea that the senior patrol leader selects the scout
who will hold each position, I haven't found anything
in the descriptions of any of those positions
that indicate someone else would be appointing those positions
or those positions would be elected for some reason.
So the process you go through with a senior patrol leader
as he makes those appointments
is a really great opportunity to work together.
I usually sit down with a new senior patrol leader
and I ask him who he wants to appoint for what position,
And in our troop we typically have an assistant senior patrol leader,
quarter master and scribe
Most of the time. I don't have a whole lot to say about the choices
that he makes, other than you know. that sounds good to me.
If he's having a tough time choosing,
I would advise him to start with any scouts
who put themselves forward for the senior patrol leader election,
because the fact that they stepped up
is a pretty good indication of their interest and commitment right.
So I advise him that he should start with his best choice
for assistant senior patrol leader
and offer him any of the positions that are open,
but tell him that he's hoping that he'll take
the assistant senior patrol leader position-
and they almost always do-
and then the new assistant senior patrol leader
and the senior patrol leader can continue going through
and making appointments.
As for your second question about whether or not
the assistant senior patrol leader should be around
when you're talking to the senior patrol leader,
most of the time when I'm talking to my senior patrol leader
it's in the context of the patrol leader's counsel,
So the assistant senior patrol leader is always there.
I think the general rule of thumb
is, when you talk to the senior patrol leader,
yeah, I think it's a good idea
to have the assistant senior patrol leader there
because he'll be listening in
and he'll get the same directions, the same mentoring,
the same training.
It's not always practicable,
but I think it's a great idea when you can make it so.
Wayne Wilcox is the scout master of Troop 184,
which is part of the transatlantic council,
because Troop 184 is located in Cobham, England,
So from across the Atlantic,
Wayne sent this question.
He said
I'm proud to say, after awarding three Eagles last year,
we have another eight scouts who will have earned
the rank of Eagle by the end of this program year.
We have a policy where we present a scout with his new rank badge
immediately after his border review
at the end of a Troop meeting-
because our boards of review
are normally held the same night as Troop meetings-
And then we recognize them
at the Troop's regular Court of Honor
by presenting the rank certificate and the mother's pin.
It's been our practice to only allow Eagles
to wear their badge of rank after their Eagle Court of Honor.
A couple of this year's Eagles will have about two months
between passing their boards of review
and the next Court of Honor.
I'd like these scouts to be allowed to wear their Eagle badge
to a council event. that happens after their boards of review,
but before their courts of honor.
Do you think allowing a new Eagle to wear his patch
prior to actually raising his hand for the Eagle charge
and pledge is permissible?
By the way, love the podcast.
Well, thanks for getting in touch, Wayne.
This is an easy answer because it doesn't involve my opinion
or my advice.
It's all pretty clearly set down in the Guide to Advancement 2013..
Now, before we talk about that,
if you're listening and you don't yet have a copy
of the Guide to Advancement 2013,.
get online, search for it-
It's available in PDF form- and then read it,
And that way you'll know the answer
to most of these questions,
or you'll have a pretty good idea
of where to find the answer.
Back to Wayne's question.
we're instructed to recognize scouts as soon as possible,
and you're doing that with guys up to Eagle Scout,
but we don't create our own rules or traditions
that change these instructions.
So here we are in the Guide to Advancement.
here are the big numbers.
Ready,
You got your pencil,
I'll wait.
Okay, here we go
In section 4.2.1.4, titled The Scout is Recognized.
it reads this:
when the Board of Review has approved his advancement,
the scout deserves recognition as soon as possible.
This should be done at a ceremony
at the next unit meeting.
His advancement may be recognized again later
during a formal court of honor.
So the only way that Eagle is slightly different
from the other ranks is that the application
has to be approved at a national level
before the insignia is issued to the troop.
So there's going to be a little more delay there.
And when we take a look at Sharpen Your Pencil,
because here's another section, number
8.0.3.0 and titled Particulars for the Eagle Scout rank.
the Eagle Scout medal or patch must not be sold
or otherwise provided to any unit or to the scout.
nor should the court of honor be scheduled
until after the certificate is received
at the Council Service Center
from the National Advancement Team.
So we find that we are instructed
to recognize scouts as soon as possible
after their Board of Review,
As soon as the advancement application has been submitted
and we have the insignia.
we want to recognize them right away
And then we can recognize them again
at the next court of honor
by presenting them with the certificate,
that little card that comes along with the badge.
And you know, if you use the mother's pens,
you can do that too.
The only difference with the Eagle is
you have to wait a little bit longer
because the National Advancement Team
needs to issue the Eagle credentials
before any of the insignia can be released to the troop.
I also want to note that a court of honor
is nothing more than a formal presentation
of the achievement.
Nothing official happens
after the Board of Review has concluded
and the certificate for Eagle is issued,
because the Board of Review
is the effective date for the rank.
A scout is an Eagle
as soon as he walks out of the Board of Review,
pending the issuance of that certificate.
The Eagle Pledge
and similar practices are basically-
they're just optional traditions.
They're not some kind of official action
that makes somebody into an Eagle scout
When there's been a long tradition.
that's kind of contrary to policies like this.
by not allowing scouts to wear
the Eagle insignia until
they've gone through the Court of Honor
and taken one of those traditional
Eagle pledges or
the Eagle charge,
there's an opportunity to review
what we're doing and align ourselves
with what we really ought to be doing.
I've heard the argument about this several times
that you're not an Eagle and take the pledge
or receive the Eagle charge
or some combination of the two,
but it simply isn't true
And it never has been to my knowledge.
I think if this were so,
the Guide to Advancement 2013
would explain exactly how that worked,
but you'll find that there is nothing there.
If you find any statements contrary to that,
I'll be glad to tell everyone.
Wayne, I hope that answers your question.
I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast.
Sounds like a great troop.
Eight new Eagles this year. Good for you.
Well, thank you for listening to this
216th edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch:
Read the blog at ScoutmasterCGcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates by email.
You can get the ScoutmasterCG app
on Google Play or at the iTunes App Store.
You can experience all the wonders
of ScoutmasterCGcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
Join the just over 5,000
who like ScoutmasterBlog on Facebook.
Tweet along with the chorus of
nearly a thousand, I think we're up to like
980 tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the Pultritudinous Pictures
Proffered Publicly with 13 other.
I'm going to get it in one. take
one of these days.
Pin the Pultritudinous Pictures
Proffered Publicly with
1,300 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
There, I did it
And watch us if you dare it.
ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
Hey, 400 odd folks
form the ScoutmasterCG
Circle on Google Plus.
But listen, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better,
if you've no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus,
that's alright. Bunky,
Zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
Email me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
and wild ideas at
Clark at ScoutmasterCGcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at
ScoutmasterCGcom.
The blog and the podcast
and all of this whole thing
here that we do.
they're not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America
and they're not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
I'm pretty sure they have bigger fish
to fry, aren't you?
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
I'm speaking of that.
Here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Oh, I thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.